senator ted cruz explains why these big
tech giants
must be held accountable explain
what the hell he's doing why they are
interfering with the election why there
are trying to censor the press and and
and we are going to get twitter and i
believe facebook
both jack dorsey and mark zuckerberg to
testify in front of the senate judiciary
committee and we need answers
before the election because this is
dangerous it is a real threat
to free speech it's a real threat to our
democratic process
here to react is the host of the dave
rubin show it's dave rubin good morning
dave good morning
good morning guys dave i think you have
such a unique perspective
on this topic because you've built a
business on the internet
the internet has allowed voices who
wouldn't have been heard to be heard but
at the same time we see big tech
companies picking which voices will be
heard
what to suppress what to elevate what
should we think
what should we feel about big tech and
the internet
and it's in its approach different
voices right now
yeah well you know it's a catch-22 for
all of us but particularly those of us
that sort of exist
as internet creatures i've i've built a
thriving and successful business
using youtube using twitter using
facebook so i want these companies to be
successful i want them
to be transparent if someone subscribes
to me or follows me or likes me whatever
it is
i want them to be able to get my content
and that's sort of the unsaid exchange
that we have with these tech companies
but ted crude is ted cruz is right we
don't know what's going on we don't know
what the algorithm is delivering us
we don't know if we're being shadow
banned meaning you you follow somebody
on twitter but you just don't see their
tweets because they don't line up
with whatever is politically correct in
the day and you know this new york post
story
the idea that twitter was suppressing
that story
regardless of how true the story is i
mean we know that there's plenty of
things that are spread online that
aren't quite true for example the very
fine people
hoax that that joe biden and the
democrats push
constantly where we know if you just
watched the full video
after charlottesville trump condemned
the the white supremacists and and the
kkk and the rest of it so if we're going
to censor things
i think people just want to see it as
fair but i also think that the bigger
issue here is that
i don't think people trust zuckerberg
they don't trust jack at twitter anymore
so
even if they are telling the truth which
generally speaking i don't think they
are and i don't envy their positions
either
um i i think they've lost the the trust
of the users
and once you lose that trust i don't
know how you get it back so you know so
far the president's been blocked
evidently
65 times joe biden's been blocked none
don jr says i've been shadow ben i can
tell
the retweets are a fraction what they
were even four or five years ago
and then we know about this new york
post story but we don't see any problem
with the atlantic story
where a third-person account of
something the president denied
saying becomes an international event
that happened two years ago
but is timed perfectly for september so
that's fact
that stage but a new york post story
with actual emails
and addresses and now a receipt with
hunter biden's
uh signature on it that can't go forward
it's not hard to see the difference here
dave
well of course then correct me if i'm
wrong guys but nobody from the biden
campaign has actually disputed the story
so the idea that a story has to be
sourced
in a specific way for it to be okay to
be on twitter is crazy i mean let's not
let's not forget there were two and a
half years of a russian collusion hoax
that everybody on twitter was tweeting
about all the time that turned out to be
totally false i mean if we were
if we were banning or suppressing views
on twitter
related to whether every single comment
was true or not i mean basically
everybody would be banned from twitter
so it's that sort of asymmetry that
people are fed up with i i think ted
cruz is right here
the question is you know we've got two
weeks to an election and and has the
has the ship left already is there
anything that the government can
possibly do
in two weeks to clean up the mess i
don't know because i think
the way we've been manipulated at this
point we're really the rubber is meeting
the road here and and it might be too
late
dave i know you attended a trump rally
in beverly hills we want to know what
that was like we're seeing all we see
the polls and it looks like biden is
ahead just like
said hillary clinton was in 2016 but
then you see these rallies
the boat shows the caravan vans what was
the turnout like
i'll tell you guys it was something else
i happened to go to one last saturday by
total accident i was just driving by and
i saw this huge trump rally and i jumped
out of my car i just wanted to see
what it was like and it was an absolute
love fest so then i went back this past
saturday intentionally
there were thousands of people and let's
just be very very clear about this
it was the complete reverse of
everything the mainstream media tells
you there were black people and white
people and
asian people and latino people and gay
people and straight people and
everybody was having fun there were tons
of american flags
but more than anything else not only
just the energy and the support and the
happiness
and the joy and smiles but the cars
driving by i mean this is beverly hills
this is the heart of lefty hollywood you
know santa monica and rodeo drive all
those fancy stores
you know pretty woman all of that and
the cars driving by that just happened
to be driving by that are not
necessarily trump supporters
the thumbs up the honks i mean i think
something is happening and it's just not
reflected in the polls i think people
have had it people have just
had it with the idea that the streets
are going to be overrun with violence
that they can't say what they think and
and really that
that they reject the far left and
trump's trump in a bizarre sense is the
only thing standing up against it
all right dave rubin thanks so much for
getting up early with us this morning
dave
really early you got it california if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell